>> LIBERAL CELEBRITIES, NOW
BACKTRACKING AFTER CALLING FOR
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO BE OUTE
OUTED.
CLAIMING THEY WERE
"MISINTERPRETED."
HE POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA THAT
HE DOESN'T SUPPORT
DISCRIMINATION OF ANY KIND AND
RETWEETED THE STATEMENT SAYING,
"I COULDN'T HAVE SAID IT
BETTER."
SO, YOU HAVE WORKED IN HOLLYWOOD
FOR A LOT OF TIME.
YOU WORK WITH A LOT OF
CELEBRITIES.
WERE YOU SURPRISED TO SEE
BACKLASH ON THE LEFT WAS TO MARK
>> THANK GOODNESS FOR WHOOPI
GOLDBERG.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH WHAT SHE
SAID.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT ERIC
McCORMICK WAS MISQUOTED.
HE SAID EXACTLY WHAT HE THOUGHT.
GIVE ME A LIST OF THE PEOPLE SO
I KNOW WHO I DON'T WANT TO WORK
WITH.
DEBRA MESSING WAS RIGHT THERE TO
BACK HIM UP.
IT WAS REALLY TERRIFYING.
HE IS GUILTY OF SAYING SOMETHING
THAT HOLLYWOOD'S IS THINKING AND
JUST ISN'T SAYING OUT LOUD.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE END OF MY
HOLLYWOOD CAREER RIGHT HERE.
AFTER THIS, I WILL BE WASHING
CARS.
IT'S GREAT.
NO, IT'S REALLY SCARY, AND
THERE'S THIS BIG RAH RAH IN
HOLLYWOOD.
BECAUSE THEN THEY ARE THE COOL
KID.
IT'S LIKE THROWING ROCKS AT A
BUILDING AND BREAKING WINDOWS.
LOOK AT ME.
I DESTROYED SOMETHING.
>> NOW, THEIR CLAIM IS THAT WE
JUST WANT TRANSPARENCY.
WE ARE JUST TRYING TO BRING
TRANSPARENCY TO THE PROCESS.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT ERIC
McCORMICK SAID.
HE SAID, SO THE REST OF US CAN
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHO WE WANT TO
WORK WITH.
THAT'S NOT ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
>> Juan: I AGREE.
I THINK THAT THAT WAS OVER THE
LINE.
I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU SEE HIM
GETTING CALLED OUT.
I GUESS THAT'S CITIZENS UNITED.
POLITICAL DONATIONS ARE THE
EQUIVALENT OF FREE SPEECH.
WELL, IF IT'S FREE SPEECH, LET
US HEAR YOU.
WE WANT TO HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY.
THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU SAW JOAQUIN
CASTRO, HE SAID, OH, HERE'S THE
LIST OF TRUMP DONORS.
THE RIGHT PEOPLE GOT SO UPSET.
HERE'S A LIST OF THE PEOPLE
STEVE ROSS IS INVITING TO A
FUND-RAISING EVENT.
WHAT'S SO SECRET?
WHY SHUNTED AMERICANS KNOW?
>> Jesse: BECAUSE THE LEFT ARE
CRAZY.
THEY WILL PROBABLY TRY TO
ASSAULT THESE PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: THE RIGHT DOES NOT
BOY CAT OR ANY OF THAT STUFF.
>> PERMISSION GRANTED.
>> Jesse: A LOT OF THESE
HOLLYWOOD ACTRESSES ARE VERY
CODDLED.
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN TOLD NO.
THEY HAVE A TEAM AROUND THEM
TELLING THAT EVERYTHING THEY'RE
DOING IS NOBLE AND RIGHTEOUS.
WHEN THEY GO OUT AND DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND SAY
LET'S BLACKLIST OUR OWN FELLOW
ACTORS AND ACTRESSES.
THEIR TEAM FINALLY GETS AROUND
THEM AND SAYS, "THIS IS TRASHY.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT."
IT'S LIKE A CHILD GETTING
SLAPPED DOWN AND THEN THEY HAVE
TO WALK IT BACK.
HE WAS VERY CLEAR WHEN HE
EXPLAINED IT.
IT'S LIKE SOMEONE STEALS YOUR
BIKE, AND THEN YOU SAY, I WAS
JUST BORROWING IT.
NO YOU WEREN'T.
YOU WERE RACING AND THE OTHER
DIRECTION.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THEY'VE GOT TO
LEARN THEIR LESSON.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE DON'T
REALLY KNOW A LOT ABOUT THE
NEWEST AND ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT, AND THEY ARE VERY
EASILY EXPOSED.
>> I'M JUST GLAD THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING OPENLY.
FOR SO MANY YEARS, THIS
BLACKLIST STUFF HAPPENED BEFORE
CLOSE DOORS.
NOW, CELEBRITIES FEEL EMPOWERED
TO PUT IT FRONT AND CENTER.
>> Dana: THAT'S A VERY GOOD
POINT.
TWITTER HAS EXPOSED A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
TWITTER IS FREE SPEECH.
IT DOESN'T MAKE IT SMART SPEECH.
SO, LIKE I SAID YESTERDAY, THIS
ALWAYS GIVES TRUMP ANOTHER MAN
IN THE GAME.
HE'S JUST LIKE, OH, I'LL TAKE
ANOTHER ONE.
I'LL TAKE ANOTHER ONE.
EVERYBODY'S GOING, OH, BOY.
YOU GUYS SHOULD IT SAY THAT.
YOU'RE JUST HELPING HIM.
IT'S PROBABLY NOT WHAT THEY SET
OUT TO DO.
I THINK THAT THEY WERE MISUNDER
INTERPRETED.
>> SO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING TO
GET BETTER OR WORSE?
IS IT GOING TO GET TO A POINT
WHERE CELEBRITIES REALIZE THAT
IF THERE IS BACKLASH ON THEIR
SIDE, SAYING, HOLD ON, THIS IS
NOT A GOOD IDEA, IS THIS GOING
TO STOP CUSTOMER >> NO.
THE TWEETING WON'T       MIGHT S
THE TWEETING WON'T       MIGHT O
THE TWEETING WON'T       MIGHT .
IT WILL JUST BECOME MORE
SECRETIVE.
YOU WILL NEVER ADMIT THAT YOU
VOTED FOR TRUMP.
LEAN TO THE RIGHT.
HOLLYWOOD IS FULL OF
LIBERTARIANS.
IT ALWAYS KILLS ME WHEN THESE
HOLLYWOOD PEOPLE LIKE JIM CARREY
IS HALFWAY SOCIALIST NOW.
IT'S LIKE, DUDE, YOU CAME TO
AMERICA WITH NOTHING BUT THE
CLOSE ON YOUR BACK, YOU WORKED
REALLY HARD, YOU HAD A SKILL AND
A WHOLE LOT OF LUCK, AND LOOK AT
THAT.
YOU'VE ACHIEVED SOMETHING.
TO HAVE THESE PEOPLE LIKE TURN
THEIR BACK ON THE AMERICAN
DREAM, IT'S SAD, BUT IT IS THE
REALITY.
>> Jesse: HE IS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE ALL-TIME GREAT COMEDIES
IN THE INDUSTRY, AND THEN HE
GOES AND RUINS IT.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK HE RUNS
IT.
BUT AGAIN, JESSE, THE JOE
McCARTHY ERA AND BLACKLISTING
WAS DONE BY PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHY NOBODY
DOES IT ANYMORE.
>> Juan: REMEMBER WHAT
HAPPENED TO JOE McCARTHY?
HAVE YOU KNOW DIGNITY?
>> Jesse: OKAY.
ISN'T IT IRONIC HOW THEY ARE NOW